premier vacciner les plus de 65 ans
seront t-il aussi les premiers
désactiver certains seigneur n'ont
toujours pas fait leur dos de rappel et
risque de perdre leur passe sanitaire
pour 400000 d'entre eux ce 15 décembre
était même une date butoir alors
beaucoup ont tenté leur chance
aujourd'hui comme au centre de
vaccination des Halles à Tours Théodore
de Carros
dans le centre de vaccination des Halles
de Tours quelques patients sans
rendez-vous ils ont plus de 65 ans et
pour certains c'était un peu la panique
au réveil
dans le train
[Musique]
et
depuis ce jour
toute personne de plus de 65 ans ayant
reçu sa dernière dose de vaccin avant le
17 mai avec jusqu'à ce mardi 14 décembre
pour faire leur dose de rappel en oublie
pour certains une difficulté à trouver
des créneaux pour d'autres ces personnes
âgées finissent par tenté leur chance
sans rendez-vous
une place
une place il y a des personnes qui
peuvent être embêter
j'ai failli
heureusement pour ces quelques personnes
aujourd'hui ça passe on parvient
généralement à l'heure trouver une dose
de moderna
depuis 9h
blagues qui sont venues parce que leur
pas sanitaire n'était plus valide donc
heureusement aujourd'hui on a une
réponse et qu'on peut vacciner du
moderne du coup on peut les prendre sans
rendez-vous en cas de doute sur la date
limite de votre rappel vaccinal de
simulateur sont disponibles en ligne
l'un sur le site internet de l'assurance
maladie et l'autre sur celui du
ministère de la Santé